bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv dans
ce cadre exceptionnel qui est le théâtre
plein air de saint-gilles
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
d'artistes est précisément de musiciens
qui vont faire vivre le festival total
jazz rencontre et sauf
bonjour santé at il pas aussi alors
christophe gonnet suez plus triste c'est
ça oui et je dis que ton style de
musique est plutôt se rapproche plus du
jazz contemporain
oui c'est ça voilà jazz fusion jazz rock
mélangé à la musique anglaise de la
réunion donc un jazz mais c'est en fait
un diaz qui a beaucoup d'influencé la
garde de musique locales de la région
donc le casque avec qui il m'a mis là le
séga bourses et pour complément des
visites sont vraiment voilà l'impression
que c'est pas ce qu'on se dit on sont
une combinaison de ça c'est que c'est
non sans calculer voilà on a tellement
accumulé tellement d influence que ce
soit par le jazz le jazz rock que ce
soit musique ici donc ça se fait
naturellement en fait voilà
j'ai vu que tu as passé 7,1 en métropole
pour parfaire sa formation va tu voyais
pas mon parcours
en fait moi moi j'ai commencé mon
parcours ici je suis parti à paris
pendant sept ans donc voilà peine
rencontre dans l'école si j'ai fait
l'ucim septième etc
et voilà j'ai ressenti le besoin de
revenir un peu mes sources déjà par
voilà pour les parents pour la famille
déjà parce que c'est toi c'est moi et de
pouvoir partager un projet de pouvoir
affiner ce projet d'album l'acquis qui
est sentie en 2015 donc donc j'avais ce
besoin là réelle et voilà le cap du coup
le festival voilà on va parler de
festivaliers juste avant je voulais
revenir sur ton instrument qu'est ce que
tu peux présenter un peu qu'est ce que
c'est que le bébé alors les lycées
électrique wind instruments en fait
c'est en réalité c'est un sac ce midi
sacré comique en fait l'image d'un
clavier m hnidy donc j'ai à peu près
huit octaves donc une grosse capacité de
son d'un gros potentiel
voilà notre beaucoup de puissance sur
ces neuf cinq en six mois c'est vrai
qu'à la réunion à paris a pas beaucoup
de gens qui nous qui joue c'est un
instrument assez particulier c'est avant
tout une guitare voilà à licorne
donc c'est une guitare mes amis cordes
donc c'est un peu différent donc ça
quand il s'agit du ferrain donc
il ya quelques personnes qui le sont
qu'ils ont qui ont développé comme
michael brecker bat melzer
donc voila moi j'ai tout de suite été
séduit par cette sonorité fusion excuses
ou voilà on va reparler maintenant que
le festival jazz à saint gilles à la
réunion devant un public réunionnais
c'est une grâce et une bénédiction
officielle
voilà c'est vraiment un privilège c'est
ma première scène un premier festival
ses premières qu'on est épais a donc
j'ai hâte vraiment d'être là accompagné
voilà le super musicien artiste d'un
leader qui a pu faire au public qui
connaît pas forcément en style musical
où le dias contemporain cette envie de
leur dire tout cet univers en fait déjà
je serai gens l'occasion d'inviter diri
leonid souka planistes mauricien donc
ces combinaisons laurent lebot teddy
baptiste et guerinoni va être
exceptionnel je pense sinon que venait
ça va être chaud ou violacées pessah des
leafs et dansant des gens participent
chante même peuvent maintenant c'est
donc christophe la dernière a sorti un
nouvel album est exactement qui a bien
fonctionné
c'était un peu un aboutissement
on vous les présente exactement donc un
album de compositions kind of blue qui
est sorti en juin 2015 ou les labels
gaïa music production
donc voilà il est sorti c'est un beau
bébé je suis vraiment content je voulais
juste vous remercier les partenaires
donc merci à martin ont permis de sortir
exactement merci christophe merci à vous
une perte au festival totalgaz l'a
découvert a très vite merci